lots of questions here we hope we can
get to the bottom of all of them we're
going to start tonight by talking to the
creator of libs of tick tock who joins
us right now by phone we appreciate your
coming on
um so i just have to ask because i'm
really interested why do you suppose the
german government wanted to shut down
your twitter feed
well i think that what i'm doing is very
effective and i think that a lot of
people
wanted to shut me down they wanted to
intimidate me into silence
and unfortunately for them that's just
never going to happen
well i'm grateful to hear that you're
not intimidated were you a little
surprised to see of all people taylor
lorenz who complained bitterly when we
used her name on the air
several months ago who whined and cried
on television because she had ptsd
because people were criticizing her
online were you surprised that it was
her who came after you personally and
tried to destroy your life
yeah i thought that was really humorous
i i it added a really nice nice layer of
humor on top of the whole story um and i
think that the fact that it was taylor
lauren
who is a known you know hypocrite
in keene
people the fact that it was her that was
doing all this um it i think it just
helps people
rally with support for me
have you noticed i mean i know you're
not a psychiatrist or perhaps you are i
don't know who you are um but are you
surprised that the people who are the
most deeply
enmeshed in narcissism who talk about
themselves the most are also capable of
the greatest cruelty have you noticed
that trend
um yes i've noticed that a lot i've
noticed it with a lot of tic tacs as
well um i think it's a little bit of a
trend on the left
yeah i i talk about i obsess over myself
so i'm willing to to hurt you so what's
your status as since we having the phone
how are you doing tonight where are i
mean you don't need to tell us where you
are but how has this affected your life
this jeff bezos piece
well it's the past two days have been
very chaotic and overwhelming um i have
to make some travel plans you know
really fast but i was not planning on
earlier so
there was a little bit of coordination
that had to happen
and i'm now in a location where i don't
think anyone would find me i'm not in
any of the locations that they reverend
leaked or that anyone can find
but
i it's been a little bit tough but i'm
not gonna let this get me down
well i hope we see you in our studio
someday thanks so much for joining us
now we appreciate it
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight